hi guys listen I had another question
about organ meats can I consume organ
meats okay so I'm going to talk about
that the first thing you need to know is
that always have grass-fed organ meats
from maybe a farmers market something
that you know is really really healthy
never consume just regular organ meats
that you would get at the grocery store
unless it's grass-fed simply because the
amount of toxic waste that can
accumulate especially in the liver okay
that being said I have never consumed
organ meats except for some liberal is
forced to consume as a child and I just
didn't like the taste but I think I do
want to start consuming some organ meats
I just have no recipes at this time but
I want to try to maybe take a
combination to grind them up and put it
in hide them in my hamburger maybe like
15 to 20 percent of it and they hammered
just because I know the benefits now you
talked about nutrient density foods
organ meats have way more nutrition than
vegetables or even sprouted vegetables
even sprouted cruciferous vegetables so
organ meats have the most nutrition of
any food that you can eat I mean look at
liver iron b12 vitamin A the active form
massive amounts folate colon zinc
methionine which is in a great amino
acid and X is a precursor for a lot of
very powerful antioxidants for your
liver selenium I mean it's really
amazing that's just a small fraction of
nutrients the kidney has loaded with
selenium and b12 brain has omega-3
specifically DHA which is a very
powerful healthy fatty acid that helps
regenerate the brain tissue and it's
like the raw material of the brain needs
again b12 vitamin C the heart coenzyme
q10 that's a very powerful antioxidant
that your cells need to make energy you
can get a lot of energy from coenzyme
q10 and believe it or not consuming
heart has that in it and I know there's
different recipes that you can make it
tastes really good it's really hard to
find a dog food that does is not loaded
with grains the other day I was I went
to this I won't even mention the grocery
store name I went in to get some dog
food
first ingredient corn
that's GMO corn and you know it's about
80% corn so I went to another store pet
store and I found some dog food that has
organ meats so I was really excited
about that it's like the whole the whole
animal the whole fish the organ meats
everything so my dog loves the food it
is expensive it's like $90 per 25 pounds
compared to the $20 one but we're trying
it out but he loves it in the morning he
just can't wait to get it but yeah dogs
can they love it our organ meats there's
a lot of nutrition in there and you
don't want necessarily give your dog's
grain so I wouldn't recommend giving
your dogs grains try to find a food that
is less grains and more what they're
designed to consume all right let me
know what you think put your comments
below hi guys hey listen I created a
pretty amazing evaluation quiz down
below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root
cause of all of your symptoms the most
likely cause so take the quiz now and
we'll send you a report